- It's the people that
are the best that win.
The market proves it for you.
So let's go in detail.
TechCrunch
doesn't pick the winners.
The Wall Street Journal
Three cool kids in the
crowd don't pick the winners.
The problem is everybody
wants to be anointed a winner
or best at what they do
before they've actually done it.
Let me just remind you
and everybody else here,
I built a business for
18 hours a day every day
running a wine liquor
store for 13 years every day
before I ever had the audacity
to come to
something like this and talk.
Let me tell you
something amazing.
If you're good enough,
you will win.
But if you are upset that
somebody else's grandpappy
got them ahead of you,
then you're gonna lose.
Everybody started ahead of me.
I'm just catching up.
("Working Together" by Jura Kez)